[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so the PS plus games this month weren't
fantastic well hopefully somebody liked
them well there's another free game
available right now which should help a
little bit and this one doesn't need PS
plus it doesn't even need a ps4 this one
is available on ps4 Xbox and PC
whichever floats your boat this is the
lego ninjago movie video game that is a
mouthful let's get one thing right
straight away this game is not here for
a long time on May 21st it will return
to full price so you need to act now if
you want this on the ps4 here in the UK
the game is hidden away meaning I only
found it by using the search function
and going letter by letter and word by
word
lego ninjago movie video game and at
some point you'll hopefully discover it
I'm told the steps are the same in the
US and mainland Europe but to make sure
I've put a link in the description below
if you're outside those regions please
let me know if it's available for you
and I'll update the comment below while
you're downloading it here's a few
details you should know just like in the
movie we battle through waves of enemies
as Lloyd and his ninja teammates running
at around 6 hours with a much more
combat focus than the other games you've
probably played in the Lego universe
this one has wall running and ninja
abilities but also the collecting studs
and building structures to open up new
areas of the levels it's the core flow
and it follows the movie story beat by
beat which is retold as we take part in
it the lego ninjago movie video game may
have the longest title you'll hear today
but if you're looking for something
different to play or have kids to
entertain during lockdown grab this
remember it goes away on May 21st so act
fast and add this to your game library
hopefully this was useful to you I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]